i've got the craziest story
that i have seen in politics in
years i think
the story has so many levels of
disinformation to it
i don't really know where to begin the
story is
the allegation
of bio labs in ukraine u.s funded
biological laboratories
in ukraine the russian government
has made an accusation that the us
is developing bio weapons and part of
the reason that they invaded ukraine was
to stop this development of bio weapons
in ukraine here is the russian
government official line we have found
europe biological materiel
it was developed primarily for military
purposes as it turns out
it was all happening in ukraine what
were you doing there it's a different
continent
it has no borders with you
there are no bases
of yours
what
were they doing there under the guise of
scientific research
so we've got it we've found that the
americans and the ukrainians are working
together to build these biological
weapons
is this claim credible or not
the russians do know a thing or two
about chemical and biological weapons
the russians regularly use at least
chemical weapons against their own
people against political dissidents they
did it to the main opposition leader
they've done it to a number of people
who've fallen afoul of putin's regime
furthermore for
most of the history of the cold war the
soviets accused the united states of
developing biological weapons usually
without any basis there's actually a
letter that was sent from the soviet
central committee in 1953 just after the
death of stalin to the communist
dictator mao zedong they said for mao
zedong the soviet government and central
committee of the communist party of the
soviet union were misled the spread in
the press of information about the use
of amer by the americans of
bacteriological weapons in korea was
based on false information
the accusations against the americans
were fictitious so we know from the
russians themselves that they have a
very long history of making false
accusations about the americans and bio
weapons
but
what about these labs what about this
accusation the ukrainians came out and
immediately denied that any of this was
happening in the kiev post they wrote
recently fake news about the alleged
activities of american military
biological laboratories in ukraine has
been spread in the media and social
networks no foreign biological
laboratories operate in ukraine
statements recently made by individual
politicians are not true and are a
deliberate distortion of the facts
okay
no
foreign biological laboratories exist in
ukraine this is bs fake news russian
propaganda so says ukraine the americans
are saying this too
so you've got the official
propagandists of the liberal regime here
in america politifact snopes the fact
checkers big tech the mainstream media
are saying this is totally fake news
there are no
right here at the sub-headline there are
no u.s run bio labs in ukraine contrary
to social media posts
and yet
just a couple days ago we played this on
the show yesterday the under secretary
of state for political affairs victoria
newland
admitted that there are in fact bio labs
in ukraine
ukraine has a
biological research facilities
which in fact we are now quite concerned
russian troops russian forces
may be seeking to
uh gain control of so we are working
with the ukrainians on how they can
prevent any of those
research materials from falling into the
hands of
russian forces should they approach
there are
biological and you can tell she didn't
want to
fully admit all of this and then rubio
diverted the questioning after that but
she said pretty clearly there are bio
labs in ukraine the relationship of the
u.s to those bio labs she doesn't quite
get into and she says we're very
concerned that those bio labs might fall
into the hands of the russians as they
invade ukraine
now the u.s embassy in kiev
through a little video that was linked
actually from one of these fact checker
websites
the u.s embassy in kiev admitted that
the u.s has a pretty tight connection
with these laboratories
the work we do in the biological threat
reduction program is complicated and
it's difficult to communicate it
sometimes to
outside audiences and i think our
adversaries like russia can take
advantage of that with some of the
propaganda that they put out the
biological threat reduction program is
working in 27 countries we feel this
disinformation and misinformation is
done just to really exploit divisions
we've had accusations that some research
projects were being used to create
threats not to identify threats and
reduce them ulterior motives are being
injected where none exist we've built
these capabilities for the partners
their central reference labs for
research they publish everything they do
they invite the international community
into their laboratories they're working
on behalf and the benefit of
the people of their respective countries
so these labs look they're just
purely scientific research to prevent
threats and then the russian
disinformation they've gone out and
they've said this is some kind of
military operation to create biological
weapons and that's just completely
ridiculous okay this is where it gets
really really weird because at the end
of that video from the u.s embassy in
kiev the
the
presenter says for more information go
to
dtra
dot mil
dot military so you've been telling me
the whole time this is just purely a
scientific public health-minded endeavor
and yet now you're directing me to a
military website because this program is
being run by the pentagon it's being run
by the department of defense okay this
is where it gets weird yesterday i said
okay i'm going to look into this i go to
the dtra.mil website
the website was down
i looked on
archive.org which will show you various
screenshots of websites when they were
online what the pages looked like and
when they go offline
the page had been up just a couple days
prior
i asked other people i said here's go to
this website what do you say i tried on
multiple devices the website was
down
you can use different vpns to make sure
have you coming through different
different ports of entry to look at the
website the website was down just one
day after victoria nuland gave her
testimony about this
then a few hours later
it goes back up
then you go over i said okay i want more
information about this program because
the argument that is being made now by
the pentagon is this all dates back to a
2005 treaty that was signed under george
w bush to dismantle old soviet bio
weapons laboratories the soviets had
developed these bio weapons after the
fall of the soviet union
about 14 years later we we go in there
into ukraine into georgia into all these
other eastern bloc
countries and we're gonna very safely
protect and dismantle these bio weapons
programs so then i went over to the
state department website where i could
find links on the internet to the
funding grants
but all the
links had been deleted
you couldn't get it there you had to go
to old versions of the the
details of these grants and so you look
i mean there were about 11 or 12 of
these on on the internet you've got them
for the kharkivo blast laboratory center
in kharkiv you've got the levive oblast
laboratory center leve you've got the
i'm mispronouncing all of these names
the state regional diagnostic veterinary
laboratory and all of the funding is
coming from not from the national
institutes of health not from the cdc
not from the world health organization
not from usaid it's coming from donor
the department of defense the united
states of america donor the department
of defense of the united states of
america donor the united states defense
threat reduction agency on
and on and on so what
exactly is going on with these labs who
who is telling the truth and if no one's
telling the truth what is the truth
about these laboratories i'm so glad you
liked that clip
ring the bell please ring that bell
subscribe and then head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your audio podcast
subscribe to the michael knowles show
maybe leave a five star review we'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]